a quick look at our covenant numbers  here nevada reporting a 16.3 percent  positivity rate while clark county is  slightly higher at 16.8 percent the  county is reporting 235 cases per 100  000 people the last over the last seven  days and that number needs to be below  100 for restrictions like face coverings  to ease  so our goal here to help you get all the  latest information in one place so we've  got the key so there's a qr code right  now you can see it on your screen  you're going to point your cell phone  your smartphone camera at it there'll be  a link that pops up click on that and  it'll take you to 8newsnow.com where we  explain all these numbers and put into a  full context of everything and you can  also find a full list of vaccinations  and testing sites across the valley